ça fait un mois jour pour jour que
l'astronaute québécois david saint
jacques s'est envolé vers la station
spatiale internationale vous voulez
savoir comment il est devenu astronaute
l'incroyable missions spatiales de
l'astronaute québécoise est raconté d'un
ouvrage houzé l'espace paru le mois
dernier est avec nous un des auteurs le
journaliste de la presse philippe
mercure bonjour dans ce livre que j'ai
lu en grande partie on découvre vraiment
l'homme
vous avez vous commencé avec david saint
jacques
enfin oui mais c'est ça nous avec mon
collègue edouard clarke fréchette ont le
suivi en reportage en entraînement à
houston aux états unis puis en russie
puis on été marquée par la fois
évidemment le métier le quai mythique
mais l'homme ou si c'est un personnage
qui est assez singulier et là en
revenant au reportage c'est 10 fois en
savoir plus donc on est allé fouiller
dans son enfance on a parlé à ses amis
d'enfance à ses parents à sa conjointe
de son médecin on est allé voir tout le
monde à qui on pourrait parler aussi de
cerner le personnage
il ya un exemple de sable je dirais de
sa volonté de réussir et d'aller
vraiment au bout de ce que plusieurs
d'entre nous auraient abandonné en cours
de route dans les nuits de la planche à
voile justement qu'il a fabriqué lui
même
oui david saint-jacques avait 14 ans
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à
14 ans qu on est adolescent david
saint-jacques lui s'était donné comme
mission de se fabriquer une planche à
voile c'est un adepte de planche à voile
et les saisies moi j'aime pas les
planches que je vois dans les magasins
je fabrique et ma propre planche à voile
et ses amis nous raconte que dans sa
maison de saint lambert justement mon
garage s'était installé un atelier il y
avait maîtriser les techniques de fibre
de verre et s'était filmé en fabriquer
des outils pour sculpter le styromousse
et au bout du compte ici fabriquer une
planche à voile donc ses amis servi
pendant à plus d'une décennie oui
pendant plusieurs années et ses amis
insistent beaucoup sur cette anecdote là
parce que ça montre que c'est gunner
d'abord il ya des idées à des projets
mais aussi il est capable de les mener à
terme
c'est pas facile à faire ça on est elle
n'est pas qu'il y ait pas d'internet et
pas de site web comment fabriquer sa
propre planche à voir l'italie fouiller
dans les livres il a appris comment
manipuler les matériaux c'est fabriquer
ses propres outils et s'approchant il
est le rêve le rêve justement d'aller
dans l'espace il l'avait mais pas
nécessairement je dirais oui il avait
mais il n'apparaît pas tous les jours
ses parents disent que enfin ils
n'auraient pas pu imaginer
nécessairement que c'était son parcours
ses parents ce qu'ils disent ils étaient
tellement intéressé par tous que c'était
difficile de voir que l'espace était
vraiment sa passion par contre lui nous
raconte que quand il y avait six ans il
ya vu une photo de la terre prises de la
lune et ce sera comme renverser tout sa
perspective il demande à son père je
comprends ça c'est la terre mais le
photographier la vie de photographies
sur la lune et ça ça l'à beaucoup marqué
et à partir de ce moment les s'est dit
il
il a pris les astronautes comme modèle
chaque fois qu'il avait des choix à
faire visiter qu'est ce qu'un astronaute
frais à ma place
l'astronaute pressé de voir mangerait
bien frais du support voyagerait et donc
il y avait ce rêve d'être astronaute
mais de l'autre côté il était très
lucide david saint jacques
on est à une époque où le canada même
pas de programme spatial et il disait je
pense pas que c'est possible pour moi de
mai l'astronome ai dit je vais quand
même avoir ce rêve là ils comparent sont
un peu à donner aux chevaliers ou
devenir samouraï
c'est un rêve impossible mais que j'ai
quand même suivi lui il est david
saint-jacques devenu aussi médecin un il
à plusieurs on l'a souvent dit plusieurs
diplômes et ça c'est assez rare je pense
quand on compare avec d'autres parcours
d'astronautes david saint-jacques nous
on rencontre puis on se rend compte
quand même fascinant le fait son génie
effet génie physique a fait un doctorat
en astrophysique après il est allé face
à médecine ce qui dit lui ce qu'il
voulait comprendre les machines donc il
le fait son génie il voulait comprendre
l'univers l'hôtel faire des études
doctorales en astrophysique et ensuite
dit je me comprenez même pas moi mais je
comprenais l'univers mais je ne
comprenais pas moi même donc étalée par
son médecin et quand on parle aux
astronomes par exemple aux astronautes
américains eux mêmes ne sont frappés par
son parcours il dit
je peux tout le monde pas tous les
astronautes qui ont un parcours comme
ceux qui sont allés faire leurs médecine
way à côté du man était très développé
absolument il faut dire que david saint
jacques après sa médecine il est aller
pratiquer la médecine
vu qu'il est allé dans des camps
palestiniens au liban 12 quelqu'un qui a
toujours été interpellé par le sort de
l'humanité qu'il voulait aider et c'est
notamment pour ça qui est allé faire ses
médecins après ses études en
astrophysique y trouver qui était avec
des concerts
j'avais besoin d'aidé ils avaient besoin
de concret donc ils paraissent du liban
c'est après les attentats à new york il
a voulu comme allez comprendre un peu ce
qui est à sous jacentes
oui il voulait comprendre et ce que ses
amis nous dise ce que pour david singer
comprendre c'est pas prendre un livre et
essayer de comprendre paroles il faut
qu'ils aient se mettre les mains dedans
donc le prix un billet d'avion hôtel au
liban et puis tu aller pratiquer la
médecine ont dit qu'un jeu quand on
parle un petit peu bon il ya ces photos
etc le regard de david saint jacques un
regard concentré oui absorbé pendant le
nomme qui s'est tout d'un homme qui est
encore en quête de connaissances oui
c'est quelqu'un qui est à la fois
confiance en lui mais il ya beaucoup
d'humilité dans la vie de saint jeures
c'est à dire qu'ils se fixent des
objectifs dont guy lacombe cette
confiance de dire je capable de
maîtriser sûr mais aussi l'humilité
je sais pas comment puis je vais la
prendre et nous on l'a vu en
entraînement dans des simulations
effectivement les cpasp injure pour lui
et ça c'est vraiment concentrés que ce
serait très au sérieux
on parle de sa famille aussi de son
épouse de ses enfants tellement de
choses qui sont intéressantes à lire la
vie de saint jacques roset l'espace
philippe mercure merci bien celui ci
pour ce livre merci